استشهد سته فلسطينيين واصيب سته عشر اخرون
برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عمليه
عسكريه نفذها بمخيم الجنين واعلنت اسرائيل
اصابه اثنين من جنودها خلالها ودانت حركه
فتحها حركه حماس وحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
العمليه الاسرائيليه واكدت انها لن تصلح
في كسر اراده الشعب الفلسطيني وانها ستزيد
الفعل المقاوم في كافه مناطق الضفه
الغربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اي حد
يمكن ربط ما تشهده الضفه الغربيه من
اقتحامات واغتيالات وحصار وهدم للمنازل
بتفاقم الازمه التي تشهدها حكومه اقصى
اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل
وما هو المدى الذي يمكن ان تذهب اليه
حكومه نتنياهو في استهداف الفلسطينيين في
سياق محاوله الهروب من ازماتها الداخليه
وما خيارات الفلسطينيين بمواجهه ذلك
كذلك ما هي احتمالات ان يؤدي هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الى تفجير الاوضاع في المنطقه
في الوقت الذي تؤكد فيه واشنطن حرصها على
تهدئه الاوضاع وتثبيت الاستقرار
[موسيقى]
بحسب بيان لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فان
السته فلسطينيين استشهدوا وجرح سته عشر
اخرون اصابه احدهم خطيره جراء اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مخيم جنين الثلاثاء
العمليه التي استخدمت فيها قوات الاحتلال
القذائفه صاروخيه ورصاصا حيا وشاركت فيها
طائرات مروحيه ربطتها قوات الاحتلال
بعمليه حواره التي قتل فيها مستوطنان قبل
تسعه ايام واكدت ان منفذها من بين من
قتلتهم في جنين
وبالتزامن مع اقتحام جنين الذي قالت
اسرائيل لان اثنين من جنودها اصيبا خلال
اقتحمت قوه اسرائيليه اخرى احياء شرقي
مدينه نابلس واعتقلت اربعه شبان فلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوتي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه من الناصره
معنا ايهاب جبارين الباحثه المختص بشان
الاسرائيلي ومن واشنطن معنا
مساعد نائب وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق اهلا بكم جميعا ابدا معك ايهاب
جبارين
موجه تصعيد خاصه من اسرائيل استخدمت فيها
طائرات مروحيه استخدمت فيها جرافات وقوات
كبيره العدد في وضح النهار
والملاحقه كانت بشراسه كبيره ما المغزمه
نريد ان نفهم ما المغزى من هذه العمليه من
هذه الموجه الجديده
ما تحاول اسرائيل في هذه المرحله فعله هو
افتعاله بدون ادنى شك السيطره على المشهد
بكل حالاته يعني في هنالك حاله اعتدام في
داخل المشهد الاسرائيلي
لثلاث جهات والثلاث جهات تريد ان تجند ما
يجري الان في داخل الضفه الغربيه لمصالحها
الشخصيه بدايه لدينا الجهات الامنيه
الجهات الامنيه بدون ان نشات هي تخشى من
تصعيد شامل في داخل الضفه تصعيد مع
المدنيين هي لا تريد اي نوع باي شكل من
الاشكال ان تحتدم الامور الى نوع من الهبه
التي تجمع كل الجبهات الفلسطينيه وحتى في
الداخل مشهد ايار 2021 هذا ما لا تريده
فبالتالي هي تحاول التصعيد الان في هذه
المرحله لكي تنادي او لكي تستقطب يعني
مواجهه مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه لمحاوله
نوع من التنفيس لانها تعلم ان كل هذا
الضغط المكمون في داخل الشارع الفلسطيني
في نهايه سوف يسبب لهذه المواجهه الشامله
بالنسبه لنتنياهو الطرف الثاني في هذه
المعادله هو بدون ادنى شك يريد ان يجند
هذا المشهد لنوع منك الكلاسيكيات
الاسرائيليه يعني المواجهه مع الفلسطينيين
هي لطالما كانت اسقاطات لكل فشل ذريع
تقتحمه حكومه كهذه او اخرى نتنياهو حكومته
الحاليه لديها فشل في خمس جبهات مختلفه
امنيه اقتصاديه قضائيه وما يعني وغيرها
فبالتالي وحتى في داخل الحكومه فبالتالي
هو يحاول ان يسقط اسقاطات المشهد بالذات
الميداني وهذا تحديدا هو النقطه الخامسه
على المشهد الفلسطيني ليحاول ان يعني
يقتبس او يشتري بعض الوقت
لتنفيذ معربه الداخليه اما بالنسبه
فاحد يعني مزايا الصراع الحالي في داخل
اسرائيل لديه الكثير من الطبقات واحد
طبقات هو صراع ما بين الصهيونيه
واستراتيجيتها الامنيه وما بين الشعبويه
التوراتيه التي تتمثل ببنك والان بين جير
الذي لطالما تغنى
بقدرته على فرض السيطره كذلك فرض السيطره
على الضفه الغربيه وكل ما يسمى بالنواه
التوراتيه الاستيطانيه وبدون ادنى شك
وبالذات بعد الكثير من شهادات الفشل التي
تلقاها من ارباب جمهور منتخبيه يحاول ان
يفرض وضع اخر مغاير في داخل هذه الصوره
وبالمناسبه نتنياهو يريد ان يستثمر الفوضى
التي من المزمن ان يفتعلها
لنهايه المطاف لكي يحاول ان يستقطب بدايه
ان يصور نفسه كالرجل العقلاني الهادئ الذي
ممكن ان يعني يهدئ الامور امنيا امام
شركائه الامريكيين من جهه ومن جهه اخرى
يستقطب بينيجانس لحكومه وحده وطنيه واي
سيناريو اجمل اللي بالنسبه للاسرائيليين
اللي حكمت وحده وطنيه من تصعيد مع
الفلسطينيه بغض النظر عن اهداف نترياه
ودكتور مصطفى التصعيد هذه المره مختلف
يعني الفلسطينيون اعتادوا على الملاحقه
ولكن الملاحقه بهذه الشراسه كيف ينظرون
اليها
هذه هي المجزره الرابعه التي ترتكبها هذه
الحكومه الفاشيه ضد الشعب الفلسطيني بعد
اريحا ونابلس جنين مرتين
وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي تستخدم فيها
دماء الفلسطينيين وتراق فيها دماء
الفلسطينيين وقودا للتنافس الداخلي
الاسرائيلي فعلت ذلك حكومه لبيد وجنس قبل
حكومه نتنياهو ولكن هذه
الشراسه التي نراها اليوم وهي مختلفه بان
ما في اسرائيل اليوم الحكومه ليس فقط
الاكثر تطرفا وعنصريه بل الحكومه الفاشيه
بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه بوجود سموتريتش
وبنجفير وانا هنا لا اعتقد ان هناك خلاف
بين مجمل الحركه الصهيونيه وهؤلاء الفاشين
لانه في اعتقادي ان هذا هو التطور الذي
جرى للحركه الصهيونيه التي تظن انها
بالفاشيه والقمع والتنكيل والاجرام تستطيع
ان تحقق هدفها بضم الضفه الغربيه وتهويد
فلسطين بالكامل وكسر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
الجنون الذي نراه استخدام الطائرات
استخدام المروحيات استخدام المسيرات
المدافع القصف بيت مدني في مدينه جنين
بالقذائف الصاروخيه هذا كله يدل على مدى
الاحباط الذي لديهم لانهم يفشلون المره
تلو الاخرى في كسر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وكلما استشهد مقاوم على يديهم ياتي مئه
مقاوم اخر ليقاوموا بدلا منه الذي يجري
صراع عميق وعنيف وقوي لان الشعب الفلسطيني
الان يدرك ان مستقبله يعتمد على تبنيه
للمقاومه ومستقبله يعتمد على قدرته على
الدفاع عن نفسه في وجه هذا الاجرام الفاشل
ومرت الواخرى جو روبن يبدو نواشنط مغرمه
بهذه الجمله
نشعر بالقلق هو نطالب الجميع بضبط النفس
في الاثناء هناك اجت ماع يجري في واشنطن
بين جيك سالفير مستشار الامن القومي
ومستشارين ومسؤولين اسرائيليين
هل هناك ما يدل على نواشن ستقدم على خطوه
تخلصها من حاله القلق المزمنه هذا ستفعل
شيء مختلف
شكرا على الاستضافه وقد وصفتم ما هو دائره
للعنف المستمر وهو امر مقلق جدا لاداره
بايدن بالنسبه للاداره كان هنالك المبادره
لعقد قمه العقبه في الاردن وهنالك قمه
قادمه في شرم الشيخ والفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين كانوا موجودين في تلك القمه
ومن اجل تهدئه هذه اعمال العنف هذه لكنها
لم تجاه اعتقد ان هنالك قلق عميق من ان
حلقه العنف ستستمر وتخرج عن السيطره وعن
ان السلطه الفلسطينيه ليست منخرطه حقا وفي
منع الهجمات الارهابيه ضد الاسرائيليين
ومن الواضح ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الان
تقوم بردود عنيفه من اجل استهدافي تلك
العناصر الارهابيه ايضا من المهم ذكر ان
الاجتماع في واشنطن
السفير السابق والمستشاره تيجي للسيد
نتنياهو كان من المفترض ان يركز على ايران
والتي تقترب بشكل متزايد من الحصول على
مواد تمكنها من تصنيع سلاح النووي هي لا
تمتلك ذلك الى الان لكنها تتحرك قدما نحو
هذا الهدف كان هذا الهدف الاجتماع لكننا
نرى اعمال العنف وهذه اعمال العنف هذه
كانت على قمه الاجنده للاطراف المنعقده
ولم يكن هدف الاجتماع لكن بالتاكيد اداره
بايدن اوضحت ان البرنامج ان اعمال العنف
في الحواره لم تكن مقبوله واعمال العنف
يجب ان تهدا واعتقد انهم سيطلبون من
المسؤولين الاسرائيلين عما سيقومون به من
اجل كسري سلسله العنف المستمره وهذا الامر
مقلق للغايه بالتاكيد في الواقع اريد ان
اتوقف عند
على تصعيد الثلاثاء ضد الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه لوزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن جفير يقول انه اصدر
تعليماته للشرطه بزياده القوات في كافه
انحاء اسرائيل هذا التهديد قابله في
الجامعه الفلسطيني تنديد بالتصعيد
الاسرائيلي واعلان الاستعداد لمواجهته
المتحدث باسم حركه فتح منذر الحيك قال في
بيان صحفي ان العدوان الاسرائيلي على جنين
وسياسه القتل والتدمير لن ترهب الشعب
الفلسطيني بل تعزز روح التحدي والصمود اما
الناطق باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم قال ان
عمليات الاغتيال والاعتقال ستزيد الفعل
المقاوم في كافه مناطق الضفه الغربيه اما
عضو المكتب السياسي لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
احمد المدلل فقال ان الاحتلال يحاول من
خلال جريمته في جنين كسر الشعب الفلسطيني
ومقاومته
ايهاب جبارين
لنتابع رد فعل اتمار بن الفير يعني لا
يبدو ابدا انه يتراجع بالعكس هو يريد ان
ينشر المزيد من القوات هو فخور بما يحصل
وهو يصفق ولكن السؤال هل الشارع
الاسرائيلي ايضا يصفق له ام هناك فعلا
ايضا حاله من القلق
بسبب تداعيات هذا
التوحش او الشراسه التي يتم فيها التصعيد
يعني كنت قد ذكرت ان هنالك نوع من الصراع
ما بين الاستراتيجيه الصهيونيه
والشعبويه
التوراتيه المتمثله ببين وهذا تحديدا هذه
النقطه يعني على نقطه الهدف لا يوجد هنالك
اي نوع من الخلاف ما بين شقين الشارع
الاسرائيلي ان كان في الائتلاف وان كان في
المعارضه ونوافق ان نحن راينا كيف كانت
حكومه
الاكثر شراسه في من الاكثر في السنوات
الاخيره ولكن ما يقلق بدايه النقطه الاولى
هو التسارع في يعني في تسلسل الاحداث من
قبل القوات الامنيه الاسرائيليه
وتداعياتها على المشهد الاسرائيلي في
اسرائيل يعلمون جيدا ان حتى يعني من
يتواجد في الداخل في الشارع الفلسطيني لن
يقف يعني مكتوف الايدي امام اراقه كل هذه
الدماء في في المشهد الفلسطيني وهم يعلمون
جيدا ان في نهايه المطاف هذا المشهد سوف
يؤدي الى يعني تصعيد الذي ممكن ان
يدفعونهم ثمنه لذلك هنالك نوع من هذا
القلق هذا بدايه
والنقطه الثانيه لا يجب ان نتداركها ان
لطالما يعني تم توظيف المشهد والتصعيدات
في داخل يعني الضفه وغزه لمارب سياسيه في
داخل اسرائيل وهذا ما يجري الان تحديدا في
المعارضه يعني ذات المعارضه التي قامت
بالتصعيد مع غزه وقامت باقتحامات في مشهد
ايار وغيره في العام الماضي هي ذات
المعارضه التي يعني
تعترض على هذه السياسه ما جرى في حوار
يعني هنالك نوع من النفاق في المشهد
الاسرائيلي ان صح القول لان كله في نهايه
المطاف يحاول تجنيد هذا الى ماربه
السياسيه ولكن في نهايه المطاف بالمجمل
الكل متفقون على النهايه يعني المشهد
الاستيطاني
الاسرائيلي وبالذات تفعيل
الضم ب ما يخص المنطقه السي تحديدا دون
غيرها هذا هنالك نوع من الاتفاقيه لكن
الاتفاقيه ليست على تسلسل الاحداث والنون
بدون ادنى شك الخطه التي يعني لطالما
تباها بها وهو الان يمكن القول يقوم
بتطبيقها ان كان في حواره كنوع من
البايلوت الذي ممكن ان يقاس ما بعد ذلك
وربما فرضه الواقع ان هذا هو المشهد وهذا
هو تحال تعاملنا مع كل القرى المتواجده في
منطقه سين
مكلف جدا على ما يبدو الدكتور مصطفى اذا
كان هو يصدر نتنياهو يصدر ازمته للضفه
الغربيه واضح ان ردود الفعل يعني اذا كان
بحجه او يبيع هذه هذا التصدير انه يريد ان
يسكت الفلسطينيين يريد ان يزيد المستوطنات
ويحمي المستوطنين العكس هو ما يجري ها هم
قاده الفصائل المختلفه فتح حماس والجهاد
كلهم يقولون اننا س نزيد ضراوه المقاومه
اذا الى اين تتجه الامور برايك
تتجه الى انتفاضه شعبيه شامله ولكن قبل ان
نجيب على سؤالك اخت ليلى بالتفصيل دعيني
اشير الى ان كلام ضيفك الامريكي بوصف
النضال الوطني الفلسطيني والمقاومه
بالارهاب مردود عليه
والارهاب هو ما تمارس اسرائيل الارهاب هو
النكبه التي ارتكبت ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
والمجازر مثل مجزره دير ياسين الارهاب هو
الاحتلال الارهاب هو نظام التمييز العنصري
الاجرامي الاسرائيلي واذا كان يريد ان
اذكر وساقول له ان الارهاب هو ممارسه
الجيش الامريكي في في سجن ابو غريب في
العراق وفي غير العراق لا نضال الشعوب من
اجل حريتها ليس ارهابا بل هو نضال مشروع
ومقاومه مشروعه في العرف الدولي وفي
القانون الدولي الذي يتيح لكل شعب موجود
تحت الاحتلال ان يناضل بكل الوسائل وبكل
اشكال المقاومه من اجل حريته واستقلاله
اما بالنسبه لنتنياهو فطبعا هو فاشل
فاشل على جميع الاصعده ولكن انا اريد ان
اشدد الموضوع ليس فقط نتنياهو وليس فقط
بنجبير و سموتريتش هؤلاء الفاشيان
المجرمان الذين كشف الوجه الحقيقي للحركه
الصهيونيه المجرم الحقيقي والشامل هو كل
الحركه الصهيونيه بكل احزابها هؤلاء
الاحزاب هم من دعموا مشروع قرار نتنياهو
لسحب الجنسيه من الفلسطينيين المعارضه ومن
معه في الحكم ولذلك المواجهه التي نعيشها
اليوم هي مواجهه صحيح مع الفاشيه
الاسرائيليه ولكن هي مواجهه مع تلك الحركه
الصهيونيه المصره على التهويد والضم وعلى
حرمان الشعب الفلسطيني من حقه في الحريه
والتي تريد ان تفرض علينا عبوديه نظام
الفورتايد والتمييز العنصري الى جانب
الاحتلال وهذا لن ينجح كما فشل سابقا
سيفشل مره اخرى بسبب اراده وصمود ومقاومه
الشعب
اساسا اترك لك الفرصه سيد روبا لتعلق ولكن
قبل ذلك اريد ان انقل ما ذكرته الناشونال
انترس مجله الناشونال انترس تقول ان اداره
بايدن اخفقت في تقدير حجم الخطر الذي
تشكله حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو وقد حان
الوقت لواشنطن لمواجهه هذه الحقيقه قبل ان
يخرج الوضع عن السيطره والسؤال هنا متى
يمكن ان يخرج الوضع عن السيطره بتقدير
واشنطن
اذا جوابا على نقطه الاخيره ان يبدو
وكاننا نتجه الى هذا هذه النقطه الى
الخروج عن السيطره علي ان اقول ان القياده
الحكومه الاسرائيليه متطرفه هذا صحيح بن
كبير بدون اي شك هو يقوم
بتنظيم الامور
برد اكثر عدائيه واكثر عدائيه مما اعتدنا
عليهم مما رايناها خلال السنوات الاخيره
ايضا النقطه
الهامه حول مساله العنف المستمر والهجمه
ضد المدنيين لن تجد حلا لهذا السر علينا
ان نجد حلا سياسيا لا نحتاج الى المزيد من
الاعمال الارهابيه ومن العمليات
الانتقاميه العسكريه على دوره العنف هذه
انت تتوقف وبطريقه ما
الامر يتعلق باسرائيل باكملها النظر الى
تل ابيب بمئات الالاف من الاسرائيليه
يحتجون في على توجه هذه الحكومه وايضا
قراراتها المحليه وهم يحتجون دعما للسلام
ايضا بالتالي الوضع معقد واكثر تعقيدا في
حقيقه الامر عن مساله اسرائيل قيامها بهذه
الامور الخاطئه ربما ليس هناك من يدرك مدى
تعقيد الوضع ايهاب جبارين من نتنياهو نفسه
هو يواجه تردي اقتصادي ويواجه تمرد في
صفوف الجيش هو ايضا يواجه ثوره وغضب في
الشارع الاسرائيلي من جراء محاوله تغيير
القوانين كل هذا يعني يجعلنا نتساءل الى
اين الى اي حد هو مستعد ان يذهب في هذه
الموجه من المواجهه وفي الهروب الى الامام
ومحاوله تصدير الازمه
هي بدون ان نشك ان ما يحدث مع نتنياهو
تحديدا في هذه المرحله دون غيرها واظن ان
تحديدا اصلا في هذه الحكومه هو تصدير ليس
فقط لازمه سياسيه بل هي اكثر ازمه شخصيه
الان نتنياهو يعني يراهن بكل يعني المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه واضف اكبر من ذلك يعني حتى في
كل المشهد الفلسطيني والصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني يراهن به فقط من اجل المزايا
الشخصيه ما يغرق منام نتنياهو في هذه
اللحظه وليس ما يجري لافت تل ابيب ولا في
جنين ولا في اي منطقه اخرى ما يؤرق منامه
تل ابيب في نهايه المطاف هو كيف يعني يمر
مرحله المحاسبه القضائيه والملفات
القضائيه التي تنظرها في القضاء
الاسرائيلي وعلى ما يبدو انه في مقابل هذا
هو مستعد ان يدفع كل شيء واي شيء لطالما
هذا يخدم نحن في الدقائق الاخيره اريد ان
انقل فقط اعطي كلمه اخيره ايضا للدكتور
مصطفى ما هي خيارات الفلسطينيين امام هذا
الواقع المعقد
بعد كل ما رايناه وبعد كل هذه المجازر على
يد الحكومه السابقه والحكومه الحاليه ليس
امامنا الا الوحده الوطنيه على في قياده
وطنيه موحده على برنامج وطني كفاحي
واستراتيجيه مقاومه والتخلي عن النهج الذي
فشل لا اريد ان اكرر ما قلناه مرارا
وتكرارا ولكن نهج التفاوضات المفاوضات
والمراهنه على حل وسط فشل فشلا درعا وفي
هذا الاطار دعيني اؤكد ان الذهاب للعقبه
كان خطا فادحا ولا يجوز ان يتكرر بالذهاب
الى شرم الشيخ لان مثل هذه اللقاءات تمنح
الغطاء لهؤلاء المجرمين الفاشيين ولا
جرائمهم ومجازرهم ضد الشعب الفلسطيني فقط
اريد ان اختم معك
بهذا التصريح لمعاريف الذي تقول ان
الولايات المتحده بعثت رسائل صريحه الى
اسرائيل انه لن يجري تعاون بشان مواجهه
المشروع النووي الايراني ما دامت الاراضي
الفلسطينيه مشتعله بمعنى اخر يعني ما يجري
يحرج ايضا الاداره الامريكيه ويضعها في
موقف هل فعلا يكفي ليدفعها لتاخذ خطوه
مختلفه
اعتقد ان الاداره تعترف انه الان فان
المنطقه على حافه الانفجار وهذا ما راينا
محاولات لمنع المزيد من مواجهات في
شهر
اذا سمحت
الخيارات واضحه ماما واشنطن يجب ان يكون
هنالك عمليه دبلوماسيه ربما الحديث انه
بعدم وجود واحده هذا الامر سيخلق المزيد
من العنف بمعنى ان اطراف العقبه يجب ان
تجتمع مره اخرى ويوافقوا على خطوات ملموسه
لتهدئه العنف اشكرك جو روبن من واشنطن
شكرا لك ومن الناصره ايهاب جبارين ومن رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوتي شكرا لكم
جميعا مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]